hey everybody is Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery Logan review video
and I'll explain why this is the most
important non Deadpool x-men movie that
they've ever made we're entering
comic-book blockbuster season so if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything
I do weekly giveaways there's a Logan
giveaway happening right now then I'll
explain at the end of the video and
there's a whole bunch of Deadpool stuff
that's gonna be happening in the next
couple of months there's a lot of
Deadpool that we'll have to reference
during this just because of the way that
movie turned everybody on their heads
turned the x-men universe on its head it
was the most important x-men universe
movie that Fox had ever made until now
it was the Regenesis the resurrection
you guys may have heard about
resurrection the comic book arc they're
bringing the x-men back in Marvel Comics
of the Fox Marvel movies because what
had happened is is that they just been
following this formula of bigger bigger
bigger
but the franchise has started collapsing
under the weight of itself in the same
thing that happened with the Wolverine
character the Fox studio chief was
really clear that behind the scenes even
after the success of Deadpool this
hardcore rated our comic book movie
there were a lot of people inside the
boardroom
they were very uncomfortable with the
direction that the Logan movie was
taking they're like this isn't the fun
wisecracking cigar-chomping Wolverine
where's that movie we were comfortable
with that the Lego Batman movie even
made fun of that idea to just a really
hilarious idea the studio executives get
really scared when movies seem too dark
but there's just so many things that
went into this movie before they made it
things that are changing behind the
scenes because of the Deadpool movie
that helped to give them this really
crazy opportunity to do a nice bookend
for the Wolverine character in this
really intimate way while at the same
time delivering on the idea of what a
comic book movie should be something
with spectacle something with heart in
regardless of what you think about the
other x-men films there's never been any
question about Hugh Jackman's
performance he is literally one of the
best things that they ever discovered in
that first x-men movie he talks about
himself in really funny ways when he
looks at that original x-men film he's
like I was basically faking it till I
made it
about 17 years ago when he was
originally first cast when they were
starting to make that first x-men film
he was still on the rise he's done a
couple movies but he hadn't done big
blockbusters like this and nobody knew
what was gonna happen but the Wolverine
character just like he became one of the
most popular Marvel characters
especially through the 90s he also
became their most popular character so
sort of the x-men universe started to
spin around him so a lot of that was
just because of Hugh Jackman's sheer
charisma sheer presence on screen in the
idea that the Wolverine is just a really
badass character usually that's what it
takes you have to have the right
character with the right actor in the
right movie and unfortunately there been
a couple of misfires but mostly like the
Fox studio chief said before Deadpool
came out and sort of proved that they
could do really hardcore movies it
doesn't all have to be popcorn
consequence-free family fare you can
tell really human stories in really
small ways and still maintain some of
the spectacle that people expect when
they go to see a Marvel movie and even
though this is x-men it's still Marvel
it still has the Marvel branding you
know you go to see those characters you
expect to see certain things in a lot of
people have been drawing comparisons to
old man Logan one of the most hardcore
Wolverine comic-book stories of all time
but it's really only loosely based on
that idea just the idea that Wolverine
is at the end of his story he's reached
the end of his rope he's that he wants
to lie down he's totally ready to die
he's this gunslinger who just seen too
many bites you've seen some of those
trailer moments where people say you
know what this means is they cocked the
guns and he's like I've heard that way
too many times
looks like mr. Lawson hires some muscle
looks that way he's a friend of my
friend with a big mouth
I hear that a lot and you probably heard
this too more than I'd like the only
thing that's keeping him going is caring
for the aging Professor X before the
Laura character enters the story and
he's forced to protect her forced to
confront his own mortality because as he
says he's seen so many of his friends
die and he just doesn't want to deal
with that anymore he like he laughs at
the idea of the comic book adventures
that Laura shows up like oh we got an
x-men fan here very little of this
actually happened and it didn't happen
the way it happened in these comic books
they do find really fun ways to work in
all kinds of Easter eggs I know there
are a lot of questions that people have
but once the movie comes out we can do
Easter eggs and spoilers and talk about
what's going to be happening next with
the character but just a place this
movie into the context of other
superhero movies if you remember when
Iron Man 3 came out it was after that
first big Avengers film it was sort of a
bookend for the Tony Stark character
Robert Downey jr. he had not renewed his
contract yet so they needed to make a
movie they could sort of be the last
Tony Stark's story which is why it felt
a little bit smaller why he threw the
arc reactor in at the end of the movie
they just needed a way to close the book
on that portrayal of that character
should Robert Downey jr. decide not to
come back now obviously that's not what
ended up happening because he came right
back in Avengers age of Ultron they
rolled back all those changes so it
became very confusing in retrospect but
Hugh Jackman has made no such promises
he said that this is effectively his
last Wolverine solo film and funny
enough there was just an interview with
Patrick Stewart Murray said Hugh has
waved goodbye to the x-men universe but
I've done no such thing yet that's not
spoilers for the movie it's just that
Patrick Stewart hasn't decided that he
no longer wants to be associated with
the x-men movies there are like so many
different time-travel trippy ways that
you could work him into the first-class
movies because there's sort of this
creative reimagining happening behind
the scenes because of what Deadpool did
and now because of what this movie did
to it just reinforces the idea that they
can tell different types of stories they
don't all have to be like those big
x-men films appealing to the broadest
possible audience in their bias
consequence appealing to no one so
whatever a crazy sci-fi twist they want
to use I'm totally down with Patrick
Stewart just popping up in random ways
throughout the x-men universe Cable is a
time traveler there are a number of
different ways that you could show
characters again no matter what ends up
happening to them in any of the movies
so it goes without saying Patrick
Stewart Hugh Jackman always solid
performances regardless of what the
script is even in Wolverine Origins I
feel like Hugh Jackman gave a good
performance with really bad material the
script the dialogue was terrible Hugh
Jackman did what he could with it we
have to talk about Dabney keen though
the Laura character she is far and away
my new favorite female character from
any comic book movie ever she's sort of
an 11 type character from stranger
things like a million everybody was
talking about her last year oh my god
who is this young actress she had this
amazing performance that was so
withdrawn just like 11 in stranger
things she has very little dialogue most
of her performance is in her physicality
in the same way that Wolverines
performances are in his physicality even
in his own Wolverine solo movies Hugh
Jackman does not have a lot of dialogue
that's just not the Wolverine character
he's not super chatty like Deadpool but
she does this really amazing job of
conveying this Wolverine type
physicality this raw rage while at the
same time being this little girl
Wolverine for example he looks like
somebody that you wouldn't want to walk
up to at a bar and mess with he has that
look about him but Laura is this little
girl she doesn't look threatening at all
that's why I love this convenience store
scene here that's in all the trailers
she looks so vulnerable just kind of
picking and choosing you know grabbing
all the candy that she can but takes it
from 0 to 100 on a dime she's so great
at that in this movie just turning on a
dime so even though this movie takes
place in 2029 way beyond what's
happening in the timeline of the other
mainstream x-men films even Deadpool I
really hope they find a way to use her
again in the x-men universe because just
like 11:00 last year she's gonna become
one of the most in-demand young actors
think about it this way xi was actually
seen on the set of infinity war just
watching them film some of those scenes
that's how in-demand she
the Star Wars people want her the Marvel
people want her so if Fox isn't careful
she's gonna get snatched up by one of
these other giant franchises but we can
talk a little bit more about the future
of this character the future of these
characters The Wolverine character when
we get closer to the movie coming out
when I do spoiler videos so when you do
have a chance to see the movie just let
me know what you thought about it in the
comments below and just be careful for
spoilers since this is supposed to be a
non-spoiler review but it was an amazing
book end for the Wolverine character one
of the most important Marvel movies that
Fox has ever made just expect to see
more stuff like this from Fox in the
future they've already talked about how
they're retooling things doing smaller
movies they're not as obsessed with
appealing to the least common
denominator and it just gonna make you
feel like they can actually make really
amazing movies like this will reignite
your faith in boxes of studio if
Deadpool didn't already do that what's
gonna happen next is is I have new flash
to post but there'll be Deadpool
happening next week
leave all your requests for Deadpool
videos in the comments below if there's
a specific video you want me to do in
the Logan giveaway is just for two imax
gift certificates all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a Logan
comment on this video in congratulations
to last week's giveaway winner lunch box
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video while you wait for that you can
click here to learn all about Marvel's
mystery Namor project and you can click
here for my black panther teaser
breakdown